I'm Tom shalu I'm Liz peek I'm Charles
Payne and this is the Fox News Rundown
Friday January 6 2023 I'm Chris Foster
President Biden's taking his first trip
to the Border then expanding an illegal
immigration Crackdown it almost feels as
if the White House realizes with the
astronomical numbers historic highs that
have happened in the last few months
they cannot ignore it anymore speaking
of Fox News Sunday host Shannon bream
I'm Dave Anthony
two years after the capitol Riot we
detail the law Congress just passed to
try to make challenging presidential
election certifications more difficult I
do wonder if there could be the
potential for Mischief in the future but
I'd say probably that this change makes
that that less likely which I think is
the point and I'm will Kane and I've got
the final word on the Fox News Rundown
[Music]
we have a patchwork system that simply
doesn't work as it should in a speech
about border security President Biden
announces a plan to accept 30 000
immigrants a month each from Cuba Haiti
and Nicaragua Turning Away Asylum
Seekers who enter the country illegally
it's an expansion of a policy covering
Venezuelan since last year and their
illegal Crossings are down the president
visits the Border El Paso Texas on
Sunday ahead of the North American
leaders Summit in Mexico City Monday and
Tuesday Texas Attorney General Ken
Paxton on Fox Business I hope it's not a
stun I hope he actually goes and listens
to mayor's elected officials law
enforcement both federal and state and
also listens to people that actually
live along the border so that he can
hear what's actually going on it's the
president's first trip to the Border
it's really interesting timing to me
because it is a chaotic situation at
best Shannon breams the host of Fox News
Sunday maybe it's to the point where the
White House realizes they don't have the
luxury of sort of you know not putting
it on the front page because it's going
to be there when he goes you've got
Democrats in Republicans across the
Spectrum who have been saying for months
going into years now we desperately need
help down here
we've got to get something done now what
the White House will always say is day
one he's been on it he offered up a
package but if it's not something that
it can actually move legislatively that
has buy-in from both sides it's not
almost even worth mentioning other than
as sort of a messaging situation but
he's going to go down there and here I'm
sure from border agents and other people
and lawmakers and ranchers and families
the reality of what's going on so it
almost feels as if the White House
realizes with the astronomical numbers
historic highs that have happened in the
last few months they cannot ignore it
anymore so they might as well just grab
it by the horns yeah I mean unless this
is back up with action like you said
it's just the criticism will then move
on to well this was just a photo op he's
going to Mexico City anyway for a summit
with Mexico's president and the Canadian
Prime Minister I mean not that Mexico
City is that close it's like 800 miles
from the border but right but still
you'd think he'd be crucial he'd be
crucified if he actually went South of
the Border and didn't go to the Border I
think that's an excellent point our own
peter Ducey has called him out about why
he would go to Arizona a border states
that's got a major problem
um with illegal immigration and you know
real chaos at the border and not go see
it so I think you're exactly right and
also you can't go there and have
conversations with foreign leaders um
and leave out this critical problem
between the borders that we share
the one way to have fewer people coming
to the United States illegally is to
have more people coming here legally and
it's apparently part of this White House
plan it's
a little bit of both there's been this
program for Venezuelan since late last
year where they LED in a certain amount
every month
um but still turn those Asylum Seeker
Seekers away at the border but if you're
allowed into the program then they that
you can come in by air for example
um now I guess they're going to expand
that to Cuba and Haiti and Nicaragua let
more of those people in but also turn
those Asylum Seekers away at the border
as we do now with Mexico and uh some
Central American countries in Venezuela
um so I guess at least there's some sort
of something 30 000 a month maybe a drop
in the bucket
well if there's a way to legally track
them and make sure that they get
assimilated into the systems and you
know that there's an accountability for
their lives and where they go and what
they're doing I think any country that
has borders is going to want that no
matter how many people we want to help
and to escape situations like
um you know the absolute disaster that's
happening in Venezuela I think America
is a very kind-hearted country we want
to help we want to assist but there's
also this responsibility in this
question about okay how do we manage
this responsibly so that
um people are funneled to the right help
when they get here and that they are you
know
um a part of our country in the way that
we would hope they would be
um and and you do have a lot of people
who say listen it's very important to
make this distinction between legal and
illegal immigration the US has always
supported legal immigration but the
numbers are so overwhelming on the
illegal immigration side we have to look
at some real pragmatic ways that could
potentially be helpful we are years
behind on immigration hearings if we
want to tell people you got to come here
leave legally but they're not going to
see a judge for years and years and
years and there are hundreds of
thousands maybe millions of cases backed
up
that's not a fix I mean if we want to
bring people here and give them a chance
at life in the American experience and
opportunity we have to be responsible in
the way that that happens but you know
when I talk to folks on both sides of
the aisle about okay what could you come
to the table and agree on you know
Republicans say until we secure the
Border nothing else and Democrats will
say well until we find a way to help the
people who are already hear some form of
amnesty or grandfathering them in we're
not going to budge um but by the
president going to the Border he's going
to put pressure on both sides to
actually try to do something
we've been talking about what we're
talking about here this Cuban Asylum
Seekers to the Border title 42 is what
it's called now the stated goal was
covet safety
um
um it seems like there's a bit of a
reversal here with the Biden
Administration first they were arguing
to let that program end
and now they're instead expanding it
um is this is it a reversal it's a
little confusing to me the Supreme Court
ruled the title 42 can stay in place
they're gonna hear arguments about it in
a month or two
yeah I think it's I think it's one of
those things that it's easy when you're
on the campaign Trail to say these
policies are horrible and they hurt XYZ
and the minute I am President we will
change all that then you get to the
White House whether you're Republican or
Democrat get the reality of the
situation and realize like whoa okay
this administration had argued against
title 42 said it's barbaric it's not
helpful to people who are trying to come
here and seek help but when it came time
to legally defend it there was a lot of
back and forth and and when it got to
the Supreme Court in this emergency
expedited basis they essentially said
okay give us a little bit more time to
plan for the lifting of it so on
principle we think it's terrible want to
get rid of it
um but we need a little bit more time to
figure out what we're going to do when
you do lift it so the Supreme Court has
not ruled on the merits as you noted
they've just kind of put the whole thing
on hold until they hear arguments
probably in February March somewhere in
there
um and we'll see but title 42 you know
there was a a dissent from those who
thought that they shouldn't keep title
42 in place one of the descends Justice
Gorsuch Rowe Justice Jackson signed on
to and he said when we have all these
policies in place that are for one
emergency but not for another that's not
how this works meaning this wasn't place
for covid were signaling and
telegraphing that that the worst of that
is over the quote-unquote emergency is
over but the chaos at the border is a
different emergency so you can't use one
policy to fix another that was never
intended to address it yeah
back along in the beginning of the bite
Administration vice president Harris
this was supposed to be her part of her
portfolio work on the border I know
she's had some meetings with Central
American leaders is there any sense that
there's been any movement on her part
there at all
critics would say no I mean she's in the
white house will say she's not about
solving the Border she's about
addressing the root causes of what's
causing the overwhelm in the crowds at
the border um but her critics will say
she hasn't been effective on that front
you know her team in the white house
will say there's been constant effort
there is constant movement in
conversation again this piece of
legislation the White House offered up
the president offered up early on but
there are no tangible results that show
any success I think if you're just
strictly going by numbers that come from
non-partisan agencies the federal
government to say this is where we're at
the numbers would suggest that there
hasn't been progress on the underlying
causes if anything they're absolutely
skyrocketing and moving in the wrong
direction so it's going to be hard for
this Administration to show any or claim
any wins on the border to this point
yeah and I guess her supporters defense
would be look you know
and her job is also the long game so we
may not right you're not going to see
immediate benefits
um let's talk about student loans for a
bit the Supreme Court is hearing
challenges next month to The Binding
Administration
for giving some student loan debt
millions of borrowers are in limbo
payments have been suspended since
coveted where are we there so I mean the
White House is also the executive branch
has said we're going to suspend this
whole thing to somewhere in the
neighborhood of January 30th they know
the court is going to rule probably in
that time frame so it's going to come to
a head this summer
um in the meantime you know the argument
from the administration continues to be
as you mentioned we've left all these
people in limbo they have uncertainty
about what's going on with their loans
and what they should do but the you know
the other side of that's going to argue
the the executive branch doesn't get to
just set up a new policy knowing it will
be legally challenged and then when it
is say oh no all these people are left
in limbo I mean you're the one who
started the change to this situation
that launched the legal action that has
now launched everyone into limbo so I
don't know that the court is going to
buy that argument this court has been
you know in the years I've been covering
it very skeptical of executive action
that they think more rightly belongs
with the legislative branch and that's
going to be the argument here is that
you know Congress alone had the power to
do something into these programs the
executive branch didn't really have the
authority under what they're using to
make these changes but I expect some
really vigorous arguments at the court
that last week of February to see where
this goes in the meantime everything
remains on hold yeah and these two
lawsuits argue that the president is
exceeding his legal Authority here the
Biden Administration says well you don't
have standing to to sue because you're
not being harmed what does it hurt you
if we forgive some of these student
loans yeah and we have you know two
different tracks as you mentioned so
you've got a number of red states that
have come to for to say that this causes
a problem for them you've also got a
private group that's representing a
couple of borrowers who say that they
are actually going to be impacted by
these decisions that are made so it'll
be interesting to see how much that
issue of standing gets I don't think the
court would take the case if they
thought it was dead on the standing
issue meaning these plaintiffs weren't
the right ones to be in court I think
they have to be entertaining at least
some possibility that they do have
standing so they can actually get to the
merits otherwise it's a judge organic
waste of everyone's time Shannon it's
the second anniversary of the January 6
right at the Capitol we've gotten this
report now from the house committee
investigating what happened they are
largely blames former president Trump I
Venture a guess though that very very
very few Americans have read a word of
that report
I think you're right
um although something that pops up in my
feed this morning said January 6 report
automatic you know incredible first best
seller at first run so there's
definitely
um some appetite for it out there but I
think people who are pretty hardcore
into the political junkie kind of world
they made up their minds a long time ago
about whether or not this committee was
doing something of substance or value
there are those who will say absolutely
we learned a lot of new information we
heard from a lot of new voices who were
directly involved and tangentially
involved with this whole thing
um and it gave us a road map of some
things that went very wrong and
potentially how to avoid these things in
the future the other side will say it
was a terrible day but we learned
nothing new it was partisan you did have
you know Republicans Cheney and
kinsinger on the panel but there was
nobody there defending president Trump
and those from the White House and
others who were considered quote unquote
on the other side at what happened on
January 6th so there are those who are
going to think it was helpful and you
know provided good information that will
help the doj and its potential
prosecution of the former president and
others and the other side it's going to
say that it was completely political
exercise that said I don't know how many
people are actually reading the report
but it's out there Sheena bream host of
Fox News Sunday Happy New Year and to
you
[Music]
this is Will Kane with your Fox News
commentary coming up
let's get back to January 6th two years
ago Mike Pence is gonna have to come
through for us and if he doesn't
that will be a sad day for our country
that was President Trump refusing to
concede he lost the election telling his
supporters that day I know that everyone
here will soon be marching over to the
Capitol Building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard they did more than
that they went on to storm the capital
and get inside interrupting the
Electoral College certification clashing
with police for hours until Congress
resumed its work and with vice president
Pence presiding and refusing to block
any votes Joe Biden was certified the
winner
congresswoman Liz Cheney on the house
committee that investigated the capital
Riot blames Trump for it he is unfit for
any office well Trump calls her a thug
and a hack and the investigation a Witch
Hunt and he's running for president
again as the committee recommends the
justice department charged the former
president criminally like more than 900
rioters have been
Congress has also made a change to try
to prevent a repeat in the future
tucked into that massive Omnibus
spending Bill last year funding the
government was the Electoral Reform Act
updating in 1887 law on certifying
presidential elections Donald Trump was
really leaning on his vice president
Mike Pence to sort of intervene in the
process and Pence I think correctly
understood that his role was ceremonial
but the law was kind of hazy on that
Kyle condick is managing editor of
sabato's crystal ball at the University
of Virginia Center for politics if you
were essentially acting in bad faith You
could argue that the vice president did
have some sort of authority to you know
throw out the electoral votes or
question electoral votes or that sort of
thing and this new law sort of clarifies
that the VP release just presiding over
this in in very much a ceremonial way it
also raises the threshold for making you
know objections to
um the the electoral votes cast by
certain States and raises to a fifth of
the members in in both the house and the
Senate and you know we had a lot of
objections particularly in the house in
2020 over the results but in some past
election years uh you know of course it
was Republicans doing that in 2020 you
did have some of that going on with
Democrats in both 2004 and 2016.
um frankly I don't think there were any
particularly great arguments made that
the votes Were Somehow fraudulent or
that sort of thing and so um you know
you you do still have a way for Congress
to address
um legitimate concerns about the vote
but it does sort of raise the bar let's
get into some of that before this law
the one that goes way back to the 1800s
one member of the House one member of
the Senate can object and start the
process like we saw what happened back
on January six two years ago but now you
have you said one-fifth so we're talking
about uh what 80 members of the house or
more that would have to object am I if
my is my math right something like that
yeah yeah and then you know and of
course 20 Senators yeah 20 in the Senate
and so you know what I would say is that
if party has like legitimate criticism
and there's some Unity within the party
they could still bring it up and the
Congress can still sort of hash it out
but I think it probably will sort of
rate it sort of raises the bars to maybe
limiting this to criticisms that are
maybe more you know grounded in in
reality than I think what we saw in 2020
um and also I think clarifying this law
I think that the rioters some of them
legitimately believe that there was
something that could be done that day to
change the vote when really there wasn't
if the law was really being followed you
know maybe that changes this perception
although again you know a lot of the
people who showed up at the Capitol were
bad actors and now are convicted
criminals so you know if people are
going to do that they're going to do
that I suspect that the authorities at
the Capitol will be more aware of the
potential of that happening
um like we saw sort of in the you know
in the aftermath of of January 6 is sort
of a you know much more of a security
presence around the capitol which on one
hand is unfortunate but I think also is
probably necessary these days one of the
other things is the there was this
effort to try to get states to put up an
alternate slate of electors and what
this new Reform Act does is the state
has to follow the laws before the
election you can't make changes after
the election to try to get an alternate
slate yeah and and you know basically
the authority as I understand at the
authority would reside in the you know
the governor to certify that that slate
of electors was the right one and there
aren't going to be other slates you know
again I still wonder if there may be the
possibility for sort of bad behavior at
some point but you know I sort of trust
in the fact that I think this was
negotiated again in a good faith way
um between I think responsible members
of both parties and that I think they're
hopeful that this will sort of help
things move forward in a more positive
way
um for 2024 you know you know we don't
have a national electorate in this
country you know everything is is you
know their elections at the state level
even for federal races and so you know
it's not like in like like France answer
something for instance you know there's
a national election and everybody votes
and the election is you know conducted
by the you know the federal government
uh or the national government but you
know here it just doesn't work that way
and so again I do wonder if there could
be the potential for Mischief in in the
future but I'd say probably that this
change makes that that less likely which
I think is the point let's broaden this
out
to the Electoral College itself
there are a lot of people especially
Democrats who want to get rid of it
after all the last two Republican
presidents won elections getting the
Electoral College majority despite
losing the majority of the popular vote
George W Bush in 2000 and Donald Trump
in 2016.
that has also happened three other times
in 1824
1876 and 1888 and there is an ongoing
attempt
to prevent that from happening again
something called the national popular
vote interstate compact 15 states in the
District of Columbia have all signed on
to it their electoral votes add up to
195.
if more States join and it gets up to
270. the compact goes into effect and
every state that's in it agrees
whichever candidate gets the most votes
Nationwide is awarded the state's
electoral votes effectively electing a
president by popular vote
but Kyle condick doubts enough States
will join at a certain point you start
you know as you as you get higher in the
electoral vote account you start moving
out of the blue States into the like
purple or even reddish-leaning States
and it's hard to identify logical
candidates that would sign out of this
thing would add up to 270 electoral
votes I mean you know maybe we get there
at some point but it seems like it's
sort of stalled out a little bit okay
but you know that effort is is still
ongoing and it's still out there yeah
because each state in that compact even
if let's say the Republican won that
state if the Democrat won the national
popular vote that state selectors would
have to go to the Democrat well but you
know here's the thing too though just
think think about this if you let's say
you have a state that signed out of this
compact then what you described happens
what if that state had a you know
republican-controlled state government
at that time would they really go along
with it or would they you know back out
would they would they change the law or
something but how do you do that again
after the election well you know
logistically speaking it's it's kind of
tricky I also kind of wonder if this new
legislation would maybe maybe prevent
that from happening although it's also
something that maybe a state could sort
of uh could maybe try to identify in
advance I just I just think it's again I
even if you got the 270 electoral votes
I don't think it would necessarily be
Ironclad the Electoral College's purpose
though way back when was to do what with
the election what was the goal I I've
read somewhere that they really believed
that this was going to lead to the house
ultimately having to decide who the
president will be which is what a lot of
them wanted they didn't believe in
popular vote because a lot of people
didn't vote in those days you had to own
property you had to be male it was a
very different electorate than there is
today yeah and really like the actual
you know the sort of presidential
elections becoming about even who you
know people who are eligible to vote you
know white men basically you know with
money you know white men with money
didn't really see that you know the sort
of Mastermind accuracy that we've sort
of come accustomed to and of course it's
the franchise has expanded and expanded
over the years but you don't really see
that start seeing that until really like
the Jacksonian period which is several
decades it's the 1820s and well he was
the first president he was the first guy
to lose uh yeah in the Electoral College
right but that that election did go to
the house
yeah that was an absolute mess and you
you sort of see the expansion of kind of
um direct you know or sort of more
direct election of the you know the
president at that time but I don't think
the Electoral College was designed as a
scheme in which you would it would it
would sort of just be like a a funnel
for for Mass democracy which is
basically what we have now and then you
also get into the reality that
um which has you know been true forever
that you know there are some competitive
States for president but the whole out
of states that aren't competitive and
the voters in those States particularly
if you're you know if you're like a
republican in New York or or if you're
you know a democrat in Nebraska like you
know or in Kansas or whatever like you
know chances are your vote isn't really
going to matter all that much and you
know we had seven states in in 2020
decided by less than three points uh
Biden won 607 those same States in 2016.
Trump won six of those seven and um you
know those are some of the states we're
gonna be looking at this time you know
Michigan Pennsylvania Wisconsin Arizona
Georgia uh North Carolina Nevada but
you're outside of some of those States
in a handful of others a lot of the
states aren't really that competitive so
it's a it's a national election decided
at the state level and really decided
only in a handful of key swing States so
again it's a it's not the sort of system
you decide design from scratch if you
were starting over again if we did
though scrap the Electoral College and
it was just whoever wins the popular
vote period what would that do to
campaigning do you think well you
probably would see uh you know
candidates travel schedules not be so
focused on these key swing states where
they just go to big cities and
population centers yeah you might be
going all over the country although even
then you know the big cities are you
know there are a lot of Republicans in
New York City for instance but as
Democratic dominated place
um and you know there are Democrats out
in rural areas too but they're dominated
by Republicans but you probably see a
more kind of nationalized campaign you
know which which would would sort of
change the you know the campaigning and
also like
um it's easy to say oh well
um and this is maybe what some
Republicans would say say I don't know
how good of an argument it is but I
think it's one you need to consider that
if in fact there was no electoral
collagen in 2000 and 2016 both Bush and
Trump would have and and Gore and
Clinton would have campaigned in
different kinds of ways and maybe that
leads to a different outcome you know
maybe the turnout patterns are different
maybe more people are engaged in
uncompetitive States than otherwise
would be you just you just don't know
until the law actually uh actually
changes you know you would also have you
know just from a logistical standpoint
because it's not an election conducted
as sort of a One Federal jurisdiction
rather as a as a you know collection of
50 states plus DC if it was super close
you would have to have a mechanism to do
recounts in every state and that sort of
thing which would you know would take
time and be expensive
um the results would be delayed to some
degree we all know there's always a lot
of conspiracy mongering when results are
delayed so there are some logistical
issues with it well it doesn't sound
like it's going to change anytime soon
no no I don't think so Kyle condick
managing editor at Sam crystal ball at
the University of Virginia Center for
politics thanks so much for joining us
thank you
[Music]
and now some good news with Tanya J
powers
a viral Tick-Tock post has given an 82
year old Maryland Walmart worker the
gift of Financial Freedom last month
Rory McCarty went to the Walmart in
Cumberland Maryland for some batteries
that's where he met Butch Marion who was
working to cash register in his checkout
line Marion who's 82 was a Navy veteran
has already retired once several years
ago to help take care of his ex-wife's
husband before he passed away after that
he went back to work at Walmart where
he's been averaging about 30 hours a
week McCarty who is an avid Tick Tock
user made a Tick-Tock post when he
bought his batteries and it got millions
of views then he set up a GoFundMe for
Marion which took only days to reach the
goal making it possible for Marion to
retire again this week McCarty presented
Marion with a check he's got your name
on it for 108 682 dollars
and 85 cents
wow
love you man I love you Marion says the
money will go to pay off bills and fund
a trip to Florida so he can see his
daughters and grandchildren he hasn't
hugged in years Tanya J Powers Fox News
put the power of over 100 meteorologists
and the worldwide resources of fox in
your hands with the fox weather podcast
precise personal powerful subscribe and
listen now at foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you get your podcasts subscribe
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your Fox News commentary
will Kane what's on your mind hey it's
Will Kane of the will Kane podcast look
you always want to keep the first thing
the first thing but that doesn't mean
you deny the existence of the second and
third thing
Demar Hamlin according to his doctors is
on the road to recovery including
regaining full neurological function
the training in medical staff at the NFL
stadium on Monday night might have just
saved the life of Buffalo Bills safety
Demar Hamlin well that
and the power of Prayer of individuals
across this nation and that is
absolutely the first thing the health
and life of Demar Hamlin
but the second and third thing still
exist reports are the NFL is considering
canceling the game between the bills
and the Bengals how does that affect the
NFL season
I mean you can't really be chastised for
acknowledging the existence of the issue
the thought in everybody's Minds the
debate being had in NFL offices and the
literal conversations coming out of
people's mouth do you just give the
number one seed to the Kansas City
Chiefs do you just vacate their records
for the bills and the Bengals a tie a
nothing just one less game for that
matter what happens to the millions of
dollars gambled on that game returned
to Bettors what about fantasy football
championships taking place that weekend
again millions of dollars if you had Big
Time Players Borough Allen Diggs playing
their points don't count it's over too
bad
millions of dollars exchange hands on a
game that's canceled I don't know the
answers to these questions I just know
they're real questions and then we can
walk and chew gum at the same time with
real ramifications
we can care about and acknowledge the
existence of the second and third thing
while still keeping the first thing the
first thing and that is being thankful
for the answer to our prayers on the
health and the life of Demar Hamlin for
more on this and other issues including
the chaos in the house download rate
reviews subscribe to the will Kane
podcast right here at Fox News podcast
[Music]
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad free on
FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple podcast
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
hear the news now you can with instant
updates from Fox News for Amazon Alexa
just say Alexa play news from Fox
Fox News it's the latest when you need
it on demand from Fox News and Amazon
Alexa